Recall, when we were examining
the motion an object,
in two dimensions, we
introduced Cartesian coordinates
and a position vector.
Now let's suppose
the object has moved
to a new point, along the orbit.
Well, we'll write
another vector r of t.
And let's say this took a
time delta t to the new point.
And what we want to
define is the displacement
of that object.
So that's a vector delta r.
And recall that a vector
of time of t plus delta t
is equal to the old vector r of
t plus this displacement vector
delta r.
Now what we want to consider is
a limit as delta t goes to 0.
And let's just look
graphically at what that means.
As we move this delta,
delta t-- as delta t
gets smaller and smaller and
our object is getting closer
and closer to its
position at time t,
and the position vector
r of t plus delta t
is getting closer and
closer to r of t delta t,
the key fact is that if we
do a tangent to the orbit,
then the limit of delta
r is approaching tangent
to the curve.
So in the limit,
delta r, the direction
is tangent to the orbit.
So that's our first key
property of delta r.
Now the second thing
we want to express
is, if we write delta
r, as a displacement
in the i-hat direction
and a displacement
in the j-hat
direction, now again,
maybe we can just clean
this up a little bit,
and see what we mean by that.
So here's our delta r.
And we have a little
delta x in this direction,
delta y in that direction.
Remember delta x or delta y
can be positive or negative.
That's all right.
Now if we want to define
our velocity as the limit,
as delta t goes to 0 of
delta r over delta t,
then what we see is we have two
pieces, the limit as delta t
goes to 0, of delta x over
delta t i-hat, plus the limit
as delta t goes to 0 of
delta y delta t j-hat.
And the definition
of these limits,
we'll write that as
the derivative dr, dt.
So the velocity is dr, dt.
And that's equal to dx, dt,
how that coordinate function is
changing in time, i-hat
plus dy, dt j-hat.
Now as far as notation
goes, we write
this philosophy as an x
component of the velocity
plus a y component of
the velocity, where
the x component,
the x, is dx, dt.
And the y component is dy, dt.
Now recall that the direction
was tangent to the curve,
but the magnitude
of the velocity,
what we call the
speed, is just the sum
of the squares of the
components, the square root.
And so now we've
describe what we
refer to as the
instantaneous velocity.
So far we've looked that a
trajectory in two dimensions.
Let's again consider
some type of motion
where we choose a positive
y-axis, a positive x-axis,
an origin, e at vectors,
i-hat and j-hat.
And I'll have some
type of trajectory,
where our object is
moving like that.
We know that at this
particular time,
the velocity is tangent to
this trajectory, at that point.
And now, what we'd
like to do, is
try to describe--
we've described
it's two components
ex and vy as a vector.
So if you did vector
decomposition,
you would write a vector like
this and a vector like that.
This is the x component.
That's the y component.
And now if I define
this angle theta,
we know that a vector has a
direction and a magnitude.
We've seen what we call
the magnitude the speed.
So that's just the sum of
these components squared,
square root.
Speed is always positive.
So we always take the
positive square root.
And now what about the direction
of this vector in the xy plane?
Well, we can see
from our geometry
that the tangent theta
is given by the y
component over the x component.
Or one could say that the angle
theta, at this given time,
is the inverse
function of vy over vx.
And so now we've described not
only the direction of velocity,
but the angle that it's making
with the horizontal axis.
And so we have now completely
described the velocity,
instantaneous velocity,
vector at time t
in terms of its two component
functions, its speed
and the angle that makes
at the positive x-axis.